To start our discussion on security in a
browser, let's start with the browser
itself. We want to be sure that the
browser that we're using is one from a
legitimate source. You don't want to
download any browser from any website
because attackers have been known to
release their own browser versions to
gain access to your system. This is
effectively the same best practice we
use for installing any software. We want
to be sure that we're not clicking links
that might be inside of an email. And we
shouldn't follow links that are going
from one thirdparty site to another
thirdparty site. Instead, you can go
directly to your browser, type in the
name of the browser that you're looking
for, and visit that developer site
directly. And in some cases, you may be
able to verify the hash of that
downloaded file to ensure that the file
that you have on your system is
identical to the installer that is on
the developer website.
To be able to perform this comparison of
hashes, we need an application or
utility that can create these hashes
based on a specific input. If you're
running Mac OS or Linux, you may already
have these utilities available at the
command line. And in Windows, there are
many utilities available in the
Microsoft Store. You will usually see
these hashes provided on the download
page. For example, I was downloading a
Linux distribution and it showed me a
couple of Linux ISOs and next to each
ISO was a Shaw 256 sum. This is
referring to this hash that's just
before the file name. This was created
using the Shaw 256 hashing algorithm.
And you can use that same algorithm to
confirm that you've downloaded this file
correctly. Once you've downloaded the
file to your local system, you can run
your own SHA 256 hash on that downloaded
file. That's exactly what I did here
using this free utility from the
Microsoft Store called hash checker. I
specified Shaw 256. I dropped the ISO
file right into the window and it
created this hash that you see on the
screen. If we compare this hash versus
the one that is on the original website,
you can see that those two hash values
are exactly the same. That means the
file that I have downloaded matches the
file that was on the developer's website
that was originally used to create the
hash. If these two hashes did not match
each other, then we have downloaded a
file that's either different than what
the developer posted and put on their
website or there was some type of
problem with the file when we downloaded
it. You'll want to do some additional
research if you want to know why the
file that you have downloaded is
different than the one that was
originally used to create that hash.
Once we've downloaded and installed our
browser, we need to be sure that that
browser is up to date. And that applies
to any browser that you might be using
on your system. You always need to make
sure that you're using the latest
version of that browser to maintain the
security of that system. Most browsers
have their own update manager, and they
will go out and check to see if a new
version is available at least once a
day. If it notifies you that a new
version is available, it may be able to
download and upgrade the entire package
all by itself.
Most browsers are fully featured
applications, but occasionally there
might be an addin or what a browser may
refer to as an extension to be able to
extend the capabilities of that browser
application. Most of these extensions
can be found on an official app store,
such as the Chrome Web Store or the
Microsoft Store, but some extensions can
also be downloaded and installed from
thirdparty websites. These extensions
have the same amount of control over
your system as your browser does. So,
it's a good idea to make sure that if
you are installing an extension that you
know you're downloading and installing
this from a known good website. If
you're downloading an extension from a
third-party website or from a website
that you've never been on before, then
it's probably a good idea to perform
some additional checks before trusting
that software on your system. This is a
very popular attack vector, and you want
to be sure that anything you're putting
inside of your browser is trusted and
legitimate. Occasionally, you'll find a
set of security researchers will go
through the latest library of
extensions. And they did this in March
of 2021 and found more than 24 Google
Chrome extensions that were identified
as being malicious. Because this
software was previously unknown as being
malicious and is being installed as an
extension and not an application, many
anti virus and anti-malware utilities
had no idea that this software could
harm your computer. The researchers also
installed these malicious extensions to
see what they would do. And they found
that many of these extensions would
steal your credentials. So when you
logged in with your username and
password to a website, those credentials
were also sent to the attacker. Some of
them made screenshots and logged the
keys that you were typing on your
computer and others would grab
information and data that you're saving
and send that information to the
attackers as well. Trust is one of the
most significant foundations in IT
security. And if we can't trust our
software, then you probably should not
be installing it onto your system.
On all of my devices, I use a
fullyfeatured third-party password
vault. This password vault is designed
to save every login credential that I
use on every website that I visit. This
ensures that I am not only remembering
what that password might be, but it
allows me to create a very strong and
very different password on every site
that I visit. If you do plan to use some
type of password vault, you need to make
sure that everything you're saving in
that vault is protected. The password
vault that I use and most of the
password vaults that you'll run into use
a method to encrypt all of the data that
you're storing in that vault. and access
to that database is often protected
using a number of different security
features. You can also synchronize this
data across all of those different
password vaults. So, if I'm using and
storing information on one computer and
I move to my tablet device, that same
password vault will be synchronized
across all of those. When attackers are
able to gain access to an authentication
database from a third party website,
they begin to use those usernames and
passwords across multiple sites. That's
because they know that people will often
reuse the username and the password on
every site that they visit. But if
you're using a password vault, you now
have a different username and password
on every single site. So if an attacker
does gain access to your username and
password information stored on one
website, they will have no way to access
any of your other accounts on any other
website. There are not only password
vaults available for personal use, but
there are also password vaults
specifically created for use in a
business environment. If you're not
using a password vault at your place of
work, you may want to look to see what
options might be available to you.
Many of us have visited a website that
popped a message up that said this
connection is not private or this
certificate is not valid or some other
type of certificate related error. Each
browser has a different way of
presenting these errors and a different
syntax that they use to describe the
error that you've received. It's often
useful to dig into the certificate and
see what specifically is causing this
browser to provide this error message.
You may find that the certificate is
expired or is using an incorrect domain
name or maybe the certificate itself has
not been properly signed by a trusted
certificate authority. And since these
certificates are also sensitive to dates
and times, you need to make sure that
your computer is also set to the correct
date and time. In this case, I'm
visiting a website at badsl.com.
This is a well-known website that you
can use to test your browser and see how
it reacts with different certificate
problems. I visited
untrustedroot.badsl.com
badsl.com. And if we show the details of
that certificate, you can see that this
is an untrusted root certificate
authority. This certificate has been
signed, but it has been signed by a
certificate authority that our browser
does not trust. Therefore, it puts a
message on the screen that says, "This
site is untrusted." If you'd like to see
how your browser reacts to these types
of problems, you can visit badssl.com
and go through a number of different
scenarios and see what messages you get
on your browser.
In the early days of the internet,
attackers found many ways to get their
malicious information in front of you on
the screen. One of those methods was to
have a pop-up window appear when you
visit a particular website. And one of
the things that you may have noticed in
the most recent browsers is that pop-up
blockers are built into the browser
itself. With the pop-up blocker enabled,
you can visit those websites and none of
those pop-up messages will appear inside
of your browser. In some cases, however,
you may find that a website does want to
provide a popup window that is
legitimate and does not have any type of
malicious use. In that case, you may
choose to disable the entire pop-up
blocker or simply disable it for this
trusted domain. Setting individual
exemptions for the website pop-up
blocker is probably the best way to
approach this. That way, you're able to
still have those pop-up messages occur
on sites that are trusted, but still
block those popups on any third-party
sites.
If you're looking inside the settings of
your browser, you'll certainly come
across one that talks about clearing
browsing data inside of that browsing
application. This often includes the
history of the sites that you've already
visited, any passwords that you have
saved in that browser, and any files
that you may have downloaded. This gives
you control over the privacy of your
system and allows you to decide how much
information is saved and what
information you'd like to delete. When
you're troubleshooting an application
problem inside of your browser, you'll
often hear tech support tell you to
delete everything in your cache and try
the application again. That's because
our browsers store a great deal of
information in a local cache so that
you're not constantly downloading the
same information from a third party
website. But unfortunately, that cache
can sometimes become corrupted or the
information in the cache may be older
than what's really on the website. In
order to work around these problems, you
can clear the information that's inside
of your cache, including things like
your cookies, any website data that may
be stored, cached images, and cached
files. There's usually an option that
allows you to specify exactly what type
of data you'd like to delete, and you
can simply clear that by clicking a
button inside of your browser settings.
Instead of visiting a website and then
deleting that from a list of websites
you visited, it might be a good idea to
simply not log that information from the
very beginning. You can do that if you
use a private browsing mode. In the
private browsing mode, you can visit
websites, but none of that information
will be stored in a cache or anywhere
locally. This is also a great
troubleshooting step since this also is
not using any pre-existing caches. You
can visit a website when you're
troubleshooting to see if the problem
you're having in your browser also
occurs if you're browsing in a private
browsing mode. On most browsers, when
you close this browsing mode, it removes
all of your history, all of your
downloaded files, and everything that
may have been cached during that session
is also deleted. This might also be a
good mode to use if you're using someone
else's computer or you're on a public
computer and you don't want to save any
of that information on that local
machine.
We store a lot of information in our
browsers. We have a list of favorites.
We have a bookmark list and we have
extensions that we've installed to
customize our use of the internet. The
problem is when you move to another
computer, those settings are not going
to follow you. However, many browsers
have a feature that allow you to
synchronize data between your systems.
You do this by logging into the browser
that you're using and then it stores all
of those configuration options in the
cloud. If you use those same credentials
to log in to another browser on a
different computer, it will download all
of those configuration options and have
them available. This way, you can move
from computer to computer and have
exactly the same environment on all of
your different browsers. This stores
information such as your browsing
history, all of your favorites, any
extensions that you've installed, and
any of the settings you have for the
user interface inside of your browser
session. This is obviously a trade-off
because you are storing a great deal of
information in the cloud, but you've
also made it very easy for you to move
from one computer to another and
maintain the same working environment
across all of those different systems.
On the internet, there's certainly a
balancing act between websites that want
to provide information and being able to
fund those websites using advertising.
Many browsers now include ad blockers in
the browser itself. This is a good way
to prevent extreme forms of advertising,
but these types of ad blockers don't
necessarily block all types of
advertising, and you may find that your
browser may not even include any way to
block ads within the browser itself.
Sometimes you'd also like to control how
much information is being stored by a
third-party website. When you visit that
website, often they will collect
information about your computer, and if
you visit again, they will recognize
that you are a returning customer. You
may want to allow or not allow that
level of tracking. And many browsers
will give you options that can set
different levels of privacy depending on
your requirements. And of course, there
is a constant battle between advertisers
that would like you to see their ads and
blockers that would like to block those
ads. These types of blockers are not
always 100% reliable, but your browser
may give you options to give you the
control over how much privacy you'd like
to have when you're surfing the
internet.
When you're at home, you're the one
who's in control over the sites that you
visit. But on a business network, you
might want to have additional control
over exactly what sites people are
visiting. One of the ways that
businesses are able to provide this
control is through the use of a proxy. A
proxy is a device that sits in the
middle of the communications flow
between all of the devices on your work
network and all of the websites that are
on the internet. This proxy receives all
of the requests that are being made from
the devices on your local network and it
makes those requests on your behalf to
the devices on the internet. This proxy
can obviously stop that query from going
out to the internet if there are
controls that prevent you from visiting
that type of website. And the proxy is
receiving all of the responses from the
web servers on the internet. So it can
look through those responses to see if
there might be anything malicious. And
if there is malicious software in that
response, it will prevent any of that
from getting on your local computers.
These proxies often have additional
functions inside of them such as
authentication, access control. They are
obviously providing URL filtering and
they may be caching information locally
so that you don't have to go out to the
internet to get information from that
web server. It can all be provided
locally if someone has previously
visited that website. If your
organization is using an explicit proxy,
then you have to configure these proxy
settings inside of your browser. Some
organizations are using a proxy known as
a transparent proxy that performs all of
these proxy functions, but you don't
have to configure anything extra on your
local system. You'll often find these
proxy configuration options in your
browser underneath the normal settings.
In Windows, for example, there's a
network and internet option and a proxy
option underneath that. This proxy can
be set up to automatically detect that a
proxy exists or you can manually
configure the proxy configuration with
exactly what's required for your
network. If this is an explicit proxy,
then you'll need to configure it either
using the automatic detection or you'll
need to manually put in IP address and
authentication details that will allow
you access to the proxy on your network.
And as we mentioned earlier, if your
organization is using a transparent
proxy, you don't have to configure
anything inside of your operating system
or browser, it will use that proxy
configuration by default. So, if you're
on your corporate network and you're not
able to connect to a third party
website, it may be that you haven't
properly configured the proxy or the
proxy itself may be blocking your
communication. Here's a standard proxy
configuration on my computer. You first
enable or disable the web proxy. You
specify the name of the proxy server
that's on your network. On my network,
it's proxy.professormeser.com.
It uses port 8080 to communicate to that
proxy server. It also requires
authentication. So, if I need to use
that proxy, I have to specify the
correct username and password before I
can communicate to the internet.
If you were to look at a packet capture
of the domain name service communication
on your network right now, you would
probably see a lot of requests being
made in the clear. You'd be able to read
all of those requests from your packet
capture. To prevent somebody from
capturing those packets and seeing that
information, many organizations are
implementing secure DNS. Secure DNS will
send this DNS information using DNS over
HTTPS.
You'll sometimes see this referred to as
DO. This is the same HTTPS we use to
encrypt our communication to web
servers. So, it's a perfect protocol to
use to encrypt our communication to a
DNS server. Obviously, the DNS server
that you're using has to support DNS
over HTTPS. Many of our large DNS
providers are already providing this
capability, and you might even be using
it, and you may have no idea that it's
even turned on inside of your browser.
On my Chrome browser, for example, under
the advanced options is the link for use
secure DNS, and I can enable and disable
that option inside of the browser
itself.
We mentioned earlier that you can
install additional extensions into your
browser from your app stores. And most
browsers will provide you with a
management frontend that allows you to
see all of the extensions that you've
installed and allows you to individually
enable or disable those extensions. If
you're in Chrome, for example, there are
links inside the Chrome browser that
says discover more extensions and themes
on the Chrome web store, and you can
click their link to visit that Chrome
web store and download additional
extensions. But you could also install
extensions from thirdparty websites.
There's nothing inside of your browser
that would prevent you from installing
those extensions. So, you need to be
sure that everything you're installing
is trusted. You'll be able to see all of
the extensions that you've installed on
your computer inside of your browser's
extension manager. And on this screen,
you can confirm that all of the
extensions that are running inside of
your browser are extensions that you
trust.